bella tutti ragazze benvenuti quando del
cazzo della musica
eccola cazzo bella tutti ragazzi e
bambini deve scoprire proprio sto
morendo
io sono bravi j oggi siamo su chi va 2
siamo stati su web 2 siamo ricorsi a
livello 22 bisogna arrivare a livello 40
per finire il gioco cosa molto semplice
si è stato molto semplice arrivare quali
con mac e più come si gioca in attimo
che niente il proiettile arriva ovunque
anche se la di in kazakistan come cazzo
lo sblocco la porta così no no no no
seria bene veramente ragazzi up artist i
artista ciò che va beh e che cazzo
il gesù ogni volta che fai un livello
che ti sembra di aver fatto una roba
impossibile in arriva uno che ancora
peggio
ecco porca [__] togliti mezzi sicuri
fuck fuck tutto il fax l'ho fatto
ragazzi non ci posso credere non ho
capito neanche io come fa a [__] non
ho capito neanche io come ho fatto ma va
bene ragazzi ne mancano 16v livelli sarà
una cosa molto lunghe porca ladra ignota
oddio cosa ho fatto
cosa ho fatto ma che cosa serve
rinoceronti qual è l'utilità di
quell'animale inutili tanto basta che
corro avanti non è che mi madonna la
troppa professionalità lega c'e neanche
così ad essi non ha timori l'ho sempre
praticamente per dirlo
invece no e veloce la cena c'era [__]
pipistrello la mer dal distacco la lite
fa ingoiare nòverca io c'è di te già è
difficile così mettiamoceli pure stinca
di pipistrelli madonna chiuso schivato
dai ti prego dove di questo queste cosa
ne penso non è così difficile il suo
gioco set
se non si è stupido è un problema che io
devo ancora risolvere perché malissimo
si no quasi è luca c'è io voglio solo
finire mi mancano dodici livelli voglio
solo finire questo giorno lo fate venire
di prego dio cioè proprio no no no no
spiegate come dovrei fare questo in
teoria dovrebbe essere il penultimo ma
non ce la farò mai
e veramente tragico dovrei arrivare alla
fine questo schivato non c'era un muro
di merda c'era un muro di merda è
comparso un muro a caso
quanta merda c'è in questo livello
spiegatemelo vabbè vabbè dai cazzo ma
con quella donna non c'è verso cosa devo
fare
nel mondo piomba [__] datemi un altro
cosa ho fatto
oddio madonna vai vedere veloce il suq a
non basta in certi casi non basta ma
neanche in matrix scriverei tanta roba
neanche il primo non riescono in chiedo
scrive colpa tua madre [__] l'ho
vista in autostrada 50 euro
neanche quelli proprio o addio
oddio no no no no non lascerà uniti
nello spin e le spine se non rischino
regalano io ce l'avevo c'erano le cose
voi siete consapevoli del fatto che non
ci riuscirò mentito arrivati in quel
punto lì porca [__] di quella merda
si spiega come ho fatto prima ma
[__] no kakà lodger mi faccio sto
livello per mimì mido all'ippica si
salva dio santo
c'era un pipistrello di merda come l'ho
superato quello schifo o anche saltato
perché sapevo che non perché sapevo di
essere stronzo sapevo che quello lì mi
avrebbe ci avrei scommesso la vita che
mi avrebbe porto io lo sapevo che dovevo
saltare prescriva no no non è andato giù
non è andato ciò non è andato giù che
mira di merda cia anche lui cosa ho
fatto
ma perché dall 8 madre l'elettroshock
adesso ci sto riuscendo
cazzo sera la corrente di merda carica
l'iphone
oddio oddio
non è stata una cosa tragica maledizione
due ore per pasta cagata se hai dei
problemi al neurone sinistro cosa cazzo
ci cade dal soffitto cosa è stato bello
ragazzi giocare a questo gioco
vi ringrazio per aver visto il video io
vado a suicidarmi è stato bello grazie a
hiroshima confronto un cazzo era
potreste mettere tre quattro bombe in
più giusto per sicurezza non ve lo dico
siamo al 30 figuriamoci che mi mancano
225.000 di livello e se vi sembrano mi
sembra normale un invito e melo se vi
sembrano perché non è possibile in sea
sta merda arrivo alla fine poi mi
ammazza pipistrelli della serie lancio
al monitor non so quale essere umano
riesce a capire che cosa sta facendo
tutto lì ma qualcos'altro anche perché
non chiamatemi sata nasce addio addio
si no no non sono né scuse di sotto c'è
una cosa sciocca i fasti giochi e poi li
deve testare per capire se funzionano
come cazzo hai fatto a fare star ho
visto livello spiega ma è una roba
indecorosa non so che cosa vuol dire è
indecorosa mantero lug e mi devono
venire sulla fronte su sull'anima prima
che finisca un po livello spiegatemelo
vai vai vai vai dai no ma come faccio
che ci sono e la ram e come faccio che
ci sono le lame
[Musica]
sì io mio dio mio
cosa è successo è successo c'è cara
delle vinse ho cercato cara delle vigne
l'altro giorno è bella è una donna bella
me lo spiegate questa cosa vi prego io
non ho capito come cazzo sia possibile
però ok se voleva ti rivelo 31 ragazzi è
bello veramente ci ho messo gli anni per
arrivare qua non voglio più continuare
questo gioco nella mia vita ma cazzo
come lo sono anche andato a beccare
proietti un genio salto no salto no
salto porca [__] o mica così funziona
ok
e siamo alla me ne manca una è quella la
giulio marino prima lo so già lo so già
lo so già lo so già sì ce l'ho fatta
perfetto perfetto 3 32 30
sono contento così per oggi va bene
verrà veramente i razzi basse ci
volevano ed io come come come come come
come come come come come come faccio
salta almeno ti prego passo che sono
esplosi non sto facendo addio e che
botte a caso qui sotto bravo bravo bravo
bravo la perfetto si si si no 2 cosa
cosa va mai dimenticato cosa
addio calmi
cosa devo fare della mia vita adesso
cosa ho dimenticato sono tutti giù tutti
pregavano capito cosa ho dimenticato
spiega c
no io senta no no no no no no
prego ti prego ti prego ti prego non ce
la faccio non l'ho toccato sì sì sì
basta basta per infili nel deretano quel
rinoceronte lo sai
basta così 33 mi fermo qua da prossima
volta attento di finirlo è impossibile è
impossibile giuro io non so come ho
fatto arrivare fin qua non me lo spiego
finisco qui l'episodio è stato tragico
tragico che i ragazzi sto male veramente
male e vero che il video vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi cosa senza se vi sia piaciuto
lasciato momento mi piace ai capace di
facebook che covano divido tra
descrizione per favore sii discreto ci
vediamo la passione belle ragazze